All right. So let's make sure that we get this concept.
So let's evaluate, tit-for-tat versus tit-for-tat, spy versus spy, and ask
whether or not they are subgame perfect, or in a subgame
perfect equilibrium with each other. And your choices are yes and no.
>> Mm hm.
>> But if you say no, I'd like you to give me a sequence to
show that it is not subgame perfect. In other words, that if they were to take
this sequence of actions and this one was to take this sequence of actions,
it would leave the machines in a position where they would not be willing to
follow through on their threat. That it would be better for them to do something
else in the long run, assuming that
they're still playing against the other tit-for-tat machine.
>> From that point on.
>> Yup.
>> Just imagine that someone could go in and change one thing.
Would you still want to follow tit-for-tat the next time step or not?
>> Yeah, I don't know
if that has to be just one thing, but yeah. That's
right. Change, change the sequence leading up to this point and
then say, okay, do you still want to do what tit-for-tat is
telling you to do, or would you rather do something else?
>> Right. Okay. I think I got it.
>> Cool. All right. Go.